it is currently three o'clock in the night in the netherlands
and I'm very very dehydrated
no kidding it's almost ten o'clock at night
and I made a wimp again
I'm going to show you how I made this first
I've already put all the fruit in my bowl
I also have ice cubes in jelly
two types of strawberry and
this should just be normal strawberry milk
so I have two just to be sure
but let's put it in first
let's put it in
yesss
something like that no more
yes i don't have sprite
but I now use a seven up is exactly the same
I don't want to hear anything
okay
ooh something like that
is going to put two of these in
this is normal yakult or yakult
here I have them
if I open them yes
I threw next to it you know
number 2
I threw it wrong again
I'm going to add another one from Jacques
so three in total
because I yes I like this
quite a big bowl and
I think three is a perfect number for that
ok then we are going to mix well and then we are
as good as ready
is yes
mix mix mix
mix ooh
I am really curious how it tastes this time
this is so good
the first time I made it
I hadn't quite made it right
and then I already liked it
but now
with the right ingredients
chefs kiss
and that jelly makes it real
this i go 100
definitely make it again